- So, let's bring out
our first guest, y'all.
He is a four time Super Bowl champion
and five time Pro Bowler.
Five times, geez.
These days you can see him
as an analyst on Fox NFL Sunday.
And he really let me down this season
because back in August,
this is what he promised me personally.
- Team that you'd bet money
on to win the Super Bowl?
- Oh, I'm gonna go with
the Dallas Cowboys.
They been making the playoffs every year.
I feel like this is the year they just,
you know, get over that edge.
(audience cheering)
- What we all thought.
That's what I thought as well.
Oh my God, I am in love with your suit.
That's my favorite color.
- Yes, yes.
Green's your favorite color?
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- Oh, mine's red and blue.
- [Kelly] It is?
- Yes.
- Very American of you.
- Yes, thank you.
- Red and blue.
- Go USA.
- Yeah.
I used to love you
until you said the Cowboys were gonna win
and then look what happened.
I don't understand.
Everybody was saying that we were gonna,
look, we say it every year, I get it.
But I really did think,
like we had all the players.
It was all there.
- I know, I did that
pick for you, too, Kelly.
- Look, here's the thing,
I yelled so hardcore.
I became that crazy fan, watch,
I got really into football this season.
I'm like into fantasy football.
Have you ever played fantasy as well?
- I've never played
fantasy football ever.
- Really?
- I know all about fantasy football.
- But you don't think about that.
Like as a football player, you're like,
"Man, what if these people
were all combined on one team?"
Well, you kind of had that because yeah.
(audience laughing)
- I actually knew how it worked.
And like throughout the
season when I was playing,
I always made sure I was like, okay,
if I can score a touchdown,
there's like two minutes
left in the fourth quarter,
we're already winning by
like three touchdowns.
But if I can somehow
sneak another touchdown in
for my fantasy owners,
they're gonna love me.
- That's what we say at
home, just walking in.
And then when you start getting
angry at the other players
that you don't have, but it's so fun.
Anyway, does it anger you that fans,
we use the word we?
We're like, "We lost" and
we didn't do anything.
(audience laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
- Actually, no, it
doesn't anger me at all.
Because without the fans,
we wouldn't have the NFL,
we wouldn't have the games.
- Good answer.
- So it's a collectivist.
So, we make sense.
- Okay.
'Cause I feel insane at the end.
My daughter's like, "Why
do you keep saying we?"
I'm like, "I used to be you, I know,
"but now I'm them."